So. The situation. So this village there. Is included.
Is there it's included in the blues as well as the neighboring village so now we have about fourteen village here that
are forming a bloc. That we were named the blues on this is very important.
And then around you you have also some Montane but the longevity is a bit lower.
So this is what I will name the light blue zone
and the rest of the country is not a long living population they are not involved in the longevity.
So this is really important this village is in the center of this area that is the blues.
So if I want to pick all the village where we saw longevity I will say that all these villages are included.
Also these one year and these one here so you have really an area like this where the longevity is the highest and
when I did it for the first time I put it in blue. So this is really the highest blue zone of.
Why does Aria the mountain around is a bit lower longevity it's lower blues on your C.
and The rest of the country years and all the blues on this without on charity
but this is really the main area of longevity. So tell me where did it. Where did it start.
In fact there is a two step further.
I was for the first time involved in centenarian study in Belgium in one thousand two with my friend.
So I was already in the field of centenarians. But this story in there were sadly now started in.
In October one thousand nine hundred ninety ninety nine
and that was because my friend my new friend Johnny Pesky medical doctor from sari arrived and explained that it.
This area. Man are living as long as women. What is really exceptional. But nobody wanted to believe this.
So they decided I remember this meeting in October where you have to.
It's clear that if you have a place where men have the possibility to live as long as women.
This is unique on Earth because everywhere on earth.
Women are I was a five star ten times in larger number compared to men and in this area you have equal number.
So you have something to find something to explain. And this is unique.
It's the only place on the on her Twitter I saw this type of work. It's clear that longevity fascinate me in that way.
Why because for everybody. Living longer is something very attractive.
In the recipe to live longer and the secret of longevity looking in all the newspaper in order.
In National Geographic it attracts so many person.
When I do a conference on longevity everybody is there at tending the conference very happy to listen.
What are the secrets of Rajiv U.T. Why why. I don't want to leave it.
OK but this is a very attractive topic
and suddenly I don't know why because I was already in the field of centenarians but. If there is a secret.
Do you have to find it on the scientific viewpoint you are to find something and it's a question I name it there.
Longevity question how can we explain that in this place men are living as long as women
and there are so many centenarian in the cemetery. Why that's a question. They're honest with you. I am a scientist.
OK. Which means that I need challenge.
And I understand not only that I was personally interested
but that a lot of people in the scientific world are interested with that topic.
It's a very attractive topic even among scientists and we have no question and I will say that at the end of the day.
I like to do it because it's interdisciplinary approach the secret of longevity is not only in one field in nutrition
in social a gene anthropology as you know it has to bring together all people to try to find the solution.
And the solution is not a simple one. If you find me a gene that explain ten per cent of the. Mortality longevity.
I say I will not be satisfied.
We have to find why there are three times or four times more men reaching ninety
and one hundred than everywhere else that's not a small difference.
This is a big difference and up to now we are not yet there. The question is still open and.
I will say that for a scientist. When question are still open. It's better than one question our source.
I will say that there is something to find and that's what research wants to do find a new line
and if we find something then I will be very happy but maybe then it will be finished for my career. This is like this.
We are coming into more every four years. When you see life like this.
In fact you have to understand that the centenarian that we meet.
We met
and we are still looking today are exceptional person they were a person that has very difficult life in their early
life. They have to work art. They were pastoring and so on and when they were sixty or seventy.
At that moment they should have some problem with health
but then the health service was improve which mean in the fifty in the sixty.
They have the possibility to go to hospital they have a matter needed they have a lot of thing.
So this is the conjunction of to change the fact that the old generation still work a lot and that a lot of effort
and a scholar request.
And that the modern world arrive with health and so on
and my feeling is that these centenarian are not by us that they are the result of these two dimensions that in future
like it is in our country.
The centenarian will be more random centenarian by as a people that they skate to this or delay this type of disease
and so on.
So the future centenarian will not be the same as the one we can see in this village
and I have already seen the situation in Okinawa in the UK in our There is no more new centenarian coming in large
numbers because since forty five the Americans arrived there with the modern style lifestyle and so on.
So the situation for the new JD they ration change fully and I'm sure that in future.
The longevity exceptional and our will disappear and this is my problem. The young generation.
If the young generation will transfer this treasure of longevity in all my talk in the municipality I say the most
important is to understand that you have a treasure with this longevity your life style your food your all what is
around you you F. To keep it that to transfer to the new generation so that you will keep this longevity.
If not you will be as a very aware some random centenarian
and nobody will take it take care of this person because they will be lost in the society in a modern society that does
not take care about the whole person. So the situation is fully different.
And what we try to do for example now in the US.
And they try to do it would also in Costa Rica is to take the lesson from this area
and to transfer in the modern world. Not to say OK go.
SHEPPARTON Sardinia No this is not possible but look at what you are eating to exercise don't stop to do this.
Physical exercise your brain social relationship.
Take care of the old person
and so all those point emerging from the lesson of this blue zone could be transferred to our society
and this is the challenge. So our work here is not only for an a piece I was a very.
Local exceptional situation is to see what these people.
What is their behavior that can be transferred for the world modern society and and in the US This is very important.
Again so basically against a lot of things like that
and in our European country the same because people now are they at ninety or ninety five.
They are put on the site just to wait to die. This is not correct here. The centenarian are on the top of the agenda.
They are the key person they stay.
In the family they are on the calendar in the municipality they are in the photograph and so on.
So the role of the oldest is fully different. And this is what we can do in our modern society. For our society. More.
It means for example that. To put people certainly in the nursing home.
It is consider in us in our society as the place where you will go to die. This is not correct.
I have seen also in the US place where you may enter in a nursing home but by step. You go first.
In the part where you stay with your spouse. Then when the spouse does appear you go to another place in the same.
Surrounding And if suddenly you became a dependent you go still in another place
but you are in a surrounding where you don't change the main problem now are they I have seen it in my country.
You have a problem of health then quickly with your children. We have to take a decision.
Poppy or mommy is to go to a nursing home and not given selected. They have to go in the only one that is available.
I have the case in my family. One girl has to go there. Suddenly within two weeks the. This is not correct.
What we what I named the last migration ration to the nursing home is the worst that can be expected by a person.
You know during the life course the less the lower level of mobility is between sixty five
and seventy five at that moment. Nobody wants to move.
But after that there is what I named the last migration the migration when you are healthy.
You are dependent either you go to your children. I go to you go to nursing home and so.
But in our country we don't go anymore to the shelter because the parents
and the Shouldn't does not want the children are not available
and the parents that don't want to borrow their their parents.
So you go to a nursing home in in my country three fourths of the oldest old are interesting.
But all the nursing all are not the same you have to know that there are some nursing home that are wooly fully
appropriate but most of them are not that good. They have no nursing only. There is nobody knows.
What is the situation in this area is that you are close to your neighbor you are close to your family your daughter is
living with you or in the neighboring house for example. Marco ear is going to spend the night with is uncle.
Once or twice a week. There is a solidarity for sorry that it is in the village and nobody knows it.
So what makes you winners. I will say that I like to enter in a field where there is.
That is not usual for all the demographer or the scientists.
Very often I see that colleagues will jump on a topic that is already written by other scientists
and just just say at the small information. In this topic.
It's a new one for the new one
and it's difficult because you have it took me ten years to prove that it's a very important topic
but nowadays I have seen it this week three three meeting that I have just beginning of this month's I have a meeting
in Tallinn in Vienna and important at the three meeting there were a lot of interest to this new concept
and that brings me. The feeling that. OK.
It was difficult to convince people convince research that is a very useful topic but after some times when you.
You keep it you succeed. And that's in all my career I did not want to have an easy way you if you made.
Shoes more difficult way but at the end of the day.
You may succeed and then it's really wonderful to see the reaction of research and so on. That's very important topic.
We are talking about you are right I will say that among the scientists.
There are very often different opportunities one opportunity is to jump in a topic that is already on the agenda of a
lot of research and then you deal with the same thing you try to do a new experimental repeat Kate as we say
and you bring some small additional information.
Another situation is when you develop and you enter in a new field in a new topic
and that's what I did here at the beginning putting on the table of the scientists a new topic a new idea a new concept
is really just for two reason they don't believe or they are jailers that that's the reason.
So for me I have a lot of difficulty but I keep the line
and may say that after fifty years the how everybody respect this concept of population on charity.
The fact that blue zone are something very interesting and there is something to take from this
and I have a meeting at the beginning of the months in Tallinn then in Vienna and in Porto at that meeting.
I talk about Luzon and there were a lot of interests
and people want really to know what is specific in these blue zone what what do you bring as new information.
So it's difficult in the carrier but when you are explorer you go in and and now in the world
and that's for me attractive you discover a place where there is no other scientists already in the field.
It's difficult but then. Brings you a lot of I would say this positive sensation.
Though the blue zone now we have four Bluto knocking in our carry on Greece Costa Rica in Costa Rica and Sardinia
and now I am always working on the possibility to find a new blue zone.
So I have been lost once in Caucasus in Georgia. And I visited a hidden valley that was supposed to be wonderful.
That has been set in the past in the Caucasus. There are people living longer. So I went there. It was attractive.
Logical viewpoint but I visited six centenarian and I did survey I check the archive at the end of my day.
I have to consider that all of them exaggerate their age. So in fact my conclusion is that there is no exception.
The longevity in Caucasus. So I close the door. Go cause this cannot be a new blue zone.
Now I have another one on the agenda this is Cuba. And Cuba.
I'm sure there is I'm sick I'm sure there is a place that I have seen a place nearby something Clara where there is a
lot of sun that I visited among the cemetery. I have some contact with the data but to prove that this is a blue zone.
I need strong started stickle data that's very important and these data are not available.
That's the problem because the government of Cuba did not give the green light. You see in Cuba.
If you don't have a sign from the top you will not have access to data that are a bit more sensitive.
And so I am waiting.
The door is open
but what is important if I succeed to prove that Cuba is a blues with health expenditure that is one thousand less than
in the US to go in the US and to tell it you need to have a strong argument you need. To have strong evidence.
So I will not do it until I have my data and my proof but if it so it will be a boom.
Because you may show that you may reach one hundred in large number in a country where you give only some small
preventive and know all these technical of medicine the new medicine
and nope sick yeah three No sickle organs a lot of things are missing in Cuba and the longevity is there.
I have seen centenarian that has no freezer at all.
There is no possibility to keep the food and they give me another nasty
and never ate so wonderful are in us the so far just piece of food.
The houses we serve but the smile on this wonderful so huge children smiling all over the world.
These are not the one that are in the richer country that's important. Now you want to know. I have another viewpoint.
All depends what you are doing in one day. OK And I understand that.
Some people at the end of the day may not conclude that they did something on that day.
Why when I see or what I'm trying to do in one day some time.
It's so heavy and so full that I think it's impossible to reach one hundred like this.
Seem that there is a different speed or a different level of activity
and so on so that finally I know some singers die at fifty but they have a full life full full full Y.
Other person die after one hundred and did not sing along side their life.
So you see there is a balance when you are doing study on the whole the old you have all the same time the idea.
I will be there soon. And. That brings me a lot of thought.
Sometimes negative so I have to fight against the negative but I have seen this person I saw the person monitors
and sixteen.
She is alone all the day I saw the mother in law of my brother she is one o one and that I discuss with her.
And I say when you are awake during the night. What this in your brain. And then she say.
Very simply I am praying not nothing else
but for me it's a question what is going on in the brain of these persons that are awake and alone a full day
and is it depression or. They are just looking on their life and and pray as she said she prayed.
That's very important for me that it put a question because the longevity is in front of all of us why marriage
children and so on. This is beyond but longevity is in front of me.
I will say spontaneously I the moment that I prefer when I feel really. The most happy. It's two different things.
When I see the smile of a small child. In the Dunn country and so on.
Smiling and I photograph your children that are so wonderful.
Or when I see a landscape like this very quiet and some landscape I have been for example in India in Kashmir
and so you have this beautiful landscape and then the problem of my fate race and I I say it's so beautiful
and for me it's these are the most important moment in my life to see those children
and the wonderful landscape that God gave us and that's very important for.
I will say that the gray wanted to say that we were Rishi easily one of the ten fifty two hundred
and even one thousand a year.
I am not convince because you say that with the new medicine you may repair everything on your body. OK but.
I will say that if you have a car and the tire is flat you repair it.
But if it is a north tire then you will have a new problem just a bit later.
I think it's a dream
and with this is a point that we are discussing very often between scientists is it an upper limit of the life.
Or it will be an open door to one thousand years old I am convinced that there is an upper limit
and our day people does not reach more than one sixteen. One seventeen is the maximum and the mom was one twenty two.
There is those change that she will be replaced very soon that that's my point
but this is a very become petition between different tire theory of demographic because some of these say OK there is
no limit and others say there is a limit and that's important.
When there is no limit it will be in that they could be a person who will reach one forty
but to reach one forty you need to have a number of centenarian that is very very large because the probability to
reach one forty is very low.
So the more you are centenarian the more you will have the possibility to go to higher page
and that's why in France for example there are more centenarians and there is one fifteen in Belgium.
It's more difficult. We reach only one to one and twelve in the Netherlands.
You have a person who reach one fifteen
but this is a casually it's not due to the fact that you have a large number of centenarian But this is random.
So I think we discussed just recently to reassure.
Eight You need to really a large number of centenarians
and at one moment the total population on earth is not enough so that you will have the possibility to have one person
for example one fifty. So this is a question. So on the probability viewpoint. It's possible.
But you need to apply this probability to initial number of person
and nine billion of population on Herc are not enough to get one person reaching one forty on one fifty.
That's the point when you look at religion actually. What's happening. So in fact.
We we were going from village to village and when you have a new village like this one.
Then you have to assess the level of this village and to assess if the level is high enough to be a blue zone.
So now we will check this village and then we will go to another one.
And finally
when the we were able to put on a map all these village we form really an area that we named the blue zone that's very
important when you look at that.
This really is part of the blue zone yes yes it's proven that means that we have already checked the data.
The next one will be also on the same situation.
So we have fourteen village that has been composing the blue zone one by one we put them together and
when you look at the villages. Forty one that are rather different.
I will say that there is not a clear difference there.
It's a gradient which means that at one moment you have to do the border to event if I What is the real arresting blue
zone the high blue zone
and then you have the Light Blues Although around that is all the mountain is part of Sardinia
and the rest of studying are included in society including all the city.
This is the number one what makes this is the level of longevity the number of centenarian that you found divided by
the number of newborn months and you really go in these villages really low
and it's because of different lives different at that that's really the question mark.
Now the fact that we didn't defy a blue zone and not blue so now we are comparing the life.
The food and Vironment everything in the two part and then we will see what are the biggest difference
and I already understood that one of the big difference is the proportion of shepherds.
So the role of shepherd in the past because in the moment in most of these people where are shepherds.
Why if you go to the plain there was no shepherd. This is not the same.
They are doing agriculture they are growing cereal and so on. This is not the same way of living.
So the difference is that the main difference for us up to now that's why the blue zone is concentrated in the area
where you have this pastoralism where you have everybody is working on the most in the thing that's inside.
And then it may be that you have the same in another country but. This is a question mark.
Which means that is it normal that with the same proportion of Shepherd in another country.
We don't have the longevity so this is a question mark. OK. If you come to be a shepherd.
I'm not sure you will live longer.
Because you should be born a year you should live exactly as they live years so it's a very complex thing.
So I don't recommend to come here to be Shepherd.
First of all nobody is shepherd now with a there are a limited number of shepherds. That's the village.
This village is part of the blue zone which means that we have been there. We check the data.
And we prove that the level of longevity is really really higher than the Italian average there is a huge difference
between the two.
So we put it on the map and putting all the village together we shaped the blue zone
and so this village is part of the blues. Well. So the first time that.
We went from village to village at one moment I decided to put on the maps all the village
and I mark in blue all the villages so that it wasn't a blue area on the map then I decide with Johnny that it was the
blues of. And from that time when we were discussing between us we always talk about the blues on.
This is a guy just at one and a few days forty one and that and a few last you know how many centennial year.
A priori you may find in the rules Senator Reed thirty at least thirty plus those who are alive
and pose preserve those who died.
Outside of the village in total you have more than forty two centenarian and then longer twenty forty two.
They are twenty two male.
And that's usually you should find among the centenarian eight women for one man only here you have the same number
that's crazy. I have another one look at this one for example this year fourteen out of. Exactly.
He was one of one when he died. And this is a man this is a girl. You see but.
We should do a meet in a hurry in the cemetery to show all those who are so you look in here you have again this is
eighty nine. This ninety and it's always like this eighty two eighty six.
You know this is ninety two and No ninety eight ninety eight.
This is for me when I visit the cemetery I want to feel this and if I come here. I will directly say there.
Something to do the research look this one is eighty seven and then you have every where. Ninety eight.
Usually the normal age of that is around eighty eighty two and so on.
When you start to have a lot of the Nashville area and or something like that then it's really amazing
and then you you say OK it's was due to start the research to understand what happens here
and here I discover it directly and my friend who work with me is a specialist of cemetery.
He is jumping in all the cemetery and once he was even blocking the cemetery because they close the door
and throw a clock and he was not able to go out
but he did systematically all the cemetery of the surrounding to check those who reach ninety
and that that's very useful people right. During one year. Last summer. Since I was there beginning of March.
There is ten people who die and among these they are four or six five Nigerian who die above ninety
and only one who die younger seventy but I would say that it's all above eighty five.
OK but at the same time you have very limited number of newborns.
Which means that the population of the village is definitely going down quite quickly by not you will increase negative
not your increase
and there's there is no immigration because the young people in one out of to decide to leave the village.
So the population of the village is going down slowly and slowly every year you have less and less people.
That's that's a problem for the survival of this type of place because more that new wall
and more immigration than immigration. That. The canal Kate Pearcy Grandy so no town taken to an IRA early..
OK John Avalon are joining up with her H.K.
The rest gameport on the part of the SHE I call born when I was a point I joined of course
and I thought I really close enough to what I came for a fruit on. Pursuit of the larger.
If I drove for a drive to Colorado uranium and that orgy. I got to hear a record.
Because I go to share some of that old time to acknowledge.
If you've obeyed if I ever say show you know go to a club or go in each that day
and I just thought that there were a lot a whole lot they missed that they should give up
and if I should have any have any problem with evil. Be very happy to minister Henri Paul and to be appointed.
So no need to. Though. Are maybe a pastoring from the past story personality Jelani a planetary aboard.
My gender we're going to rally. Look Past story.
So not to look to the law no Alistair Oh no not be like Gandhi highly bad also.
No not really wanted todo you have to retrain Jay one time then you know Jane to well go that way saying it's about
time.
Or like a plan which I don't I can't just yeah I was not being just other you reject at the very minute an hour later I
said Of course I really know that they're all taking a pinnacle of energy
and I can't have time for seven July last row. I should have done that a little mystery.
My dad rejected if I give if you don't I think you know me because. None of I'm going to have a go. When I go back.
I don't I think you are going to show up here. Because you were held up you. Yelled A.J.
What I want of a girl is a rose.
And I think the very thought of yet you don't tip or yeah you know they reach your motto.
But you know you know because it's a lot of time but anyway so I know we start on T V equally. There's a lot of it.
Let me type I thought everything Sharma dismissed out of my dream. What are the three big. Sandra. You know about it.
Boy. Give me time anyway. My son had a lot. Yep and if I mean and I'm just not going to rally away the plan so grand.
The musky Levy Valon go and see him. Not a mother. Mandy needed Talia lead don't need long go girl.
I'm asking my ground though there must be you must trip you. They must be told.
I'll pay you if you show her she was stupid of event that actually she thinks I'll give it a go.
It's all very good to try woman it only I did only about the love I want from his ordinary man General No I was there
my love never ran she has a party girl I know she may have a lot.
I know well it's a little too probable go to Goree the G.D.B.
She did it as a party and all
or an order my lid on it was made out to play Nobel of a little more love don't know don't have it about nobody
but you know it. Very even more shame me or your heart and only Valladolid come by next week.
You know Gordon it was all me whether living here already or you know I don't know
but I stank you call me no he she forgot about Janet because of her I'm sorry. She.
She went on as if joining a little on a level route or if I mean actually or more to every corner.
When out of the Fair around say probably a one dollar lay a bambino. I got legacy. I got differences. Feel.
Davi love Warrick mama motley feel your life feeling the Belmont Danya for my moderation. Are these.
Only the coming out of the ground the S.N.C. Suffer. Param that retort No even trying.
If you've got time for Michael really tricky. He can take you know gradually.
I love the lab results haven't peed the gentle jittery Oh who want to reform in Vermont or.
If you prevented record your uncle.
If you live in the here if he said to mother all or all go to Jordan a little I do want to have also a very minor.
When I want to presenting the love I have ever been to R.T.
What I want of me as a man of OK late Dominick I don't
and I want our feely initio love OTOH committed perjury saying I said they are all to run for my jewelry to inoculate
the command scum and. Say I said they are auto all of them in a riot.
I pretty much but even like ours are doing throw to prevent the.
The liberal daily with a lot of money already you know.
And nobody has a party line and no lushly Montana is only a lame merriness and I'm right
and you know better go to sleep but over it. Look over if you're growing a hell of a period.
That I would prefer the land by me. You know Thoreau pay he might you know generator Oh well the trees are not.
Carolyn much additional letter he will talk out of out of their Torah their quote on.
You never got caught on drugs not your own.
I mean attorney general tried to me about a job for me about how to go home.
I mean
and I meet you in your private jet a little market historic you know the corridor the little story element in a park on
a pedestal is up to all of us who are modern enough US not just your it's my problem and. You know remember your lover.
OK recent times you're learning. You cannot enjoy mine. And so you have to manage train no one around.
The time the introductions are for. And then I'll remind you all and they are a no brainer. A lot. No problem. Oh gee.
They're a little discouraging to have intervened in a little new generation they don't have any book
or distorted public a quick look at their phone I lay and said don't. So it's a problem. I'm still not Pretty Polly.
Read through the lousy bit up there lay me way you know very far it Vivaah long ago. I really don't know.
And I just might add. I got tons of minestrone very a lot of. You know coming out. My goodness what Paul or not.
Molly at all really. Most of all to talk about at all. K.-Mart I want I want to honor Miley not at all.
She might have a panther if she can mean I have a moral to her she got another minestrone a lot of dough.
You know my got a record that records are going to share.
Oh he has a G two Remind yourself of the last night they tell you he had the money.
I mean you have to turn to I mean after more physical access to see say a better coming out and then piano.
And a lot of story. Regional Jet into you know coming up to more tournaments on time. Yeah he's a.